Unlike in live-action cinematography
lighting in animation is something that's built totally
from scratch.
In other words while in live-action light is controlled
sometimes too brilliant effect
in animation.
Light is created.
Of course these days a lot of animated light is computer-generated meaning that virtual lights can be placed
in 3D environments and actually play off solid surfaces
like they would in real life.
Like to control of actual lights this too can be used to beautiful effect
but today I want to talk about lighting as it was done in traditional hand-drawn Cel animation
particularly in the groundbreaking anime film by Katsuhiro Otomo
Akira (1988)
Now Akira is well known for its painstaking animation.
Every frame of the film was composed
with the closest attention to detail and color
and that gives it an
unmatched richness and soul.
For this reason Akira is also a film
that's been painstakingly picked over and analyzed by others.
But one thing I haven't heard much about is the way that lighting is used by the filmmakers.
Because I see the film's many lights.
Their different qualities and textures.
As a powerful motif and symbol and a vital element
of its genius.
"The celluloids and backgrounds must still be photographed
by the Master camera in technicolor.
Here, the operator puts a Donald Duck celluloid on top of a background
as the overhead camera exposes one frame of film."
Like I said, Akira was a film made in
the Cel Animation style developed in the first half of the 20th century
which involves drawing and painting onto
transparent slides and layering them over a background.
Frames composed like this were photographed and strung together
to create the animation.
This 2D traditional style coupled with the tropes
of anime
means that the light in Akira is
quite specific and pronounced.
The lines between shadow and light are
distinct and evocative in the same way that
film noir lighting is.
And like in film noir, light in Akira is...
intimately connected to the city
at night.
This for example is the very first shot after the opening credits
a flickering neon sign
for the neighborhood bar where Kaneda
is waiting for his friends.
Nothing could more concisely
communicate the rundown dystopic feeling
of the future Tokyo, Otomo is going to present us with
in the very next shot
and throughout the film.
Indeed, this is a city as sort it
romantic and multifarious
as the lights that slash across its million surfaces to make a delicate hole.
The city where the disenfranchised young
marked their presence and their personalities
with the streaks of light that their motorcycles leave behind.
A city where authority is as much
a blinding spotlight
as it is a gun or badge.
Otomo has said that he wanted Tokyo itself to be a major character
in Akira
and one of the ways he flushes this out is with light.
Particularly,
Neon.
Neon has a special significance for both, Tokyo and the Cyberpunk genre.
It is the bitter
but beautiful light that signifies both the colorful radiance
and the gaudy consumerism of modernity.
The dark dystopic side of which remains Cyberpunk's
basic focus.
Tokyo for its part has been a cultural hub for neon signage.
Ever since 1957
when the
Totsuko company unveiled its giant 30-foot Neon billboard
in the Ginza district
revealing its new name
SONY.
Since then the signs have proliferated
becoming a signature even
a attraction of Tokyo's night scape.
And novels like William Gibson's "Neuromancer" films like
Blade Runner (1982)
took the vivid and suggestive qualities of Tokyo's Neon
as their palette for a bleak.
Tech-saturated future.
Akira continues this tradition, but here the neon quality
infuses all the light sources of the film
both inside and out.
There's the neon on the buildings
but there's also the neon bright screens that shine in the characters faces
and the neon control panels of right primary colors.
The spotlights that rove in the sky are like giant neon tubes being waved back and forth.
Machine-gun fire is a barrage of neon streaks.
Even the sunlight shining in through the windows has a bluish neon quality to it.
In neon, Neo Tokyo and its inhabitants aren't so much lit
as caught.
Caught in this huge incandescent web that serves
only the mandates of...
money.
"Capital"
In that web, government is as impotent as a biker gang made up of disaffected children.
It's funny that industry business is notably absent from the film's plot because
its DNA seems to be in the corners of everything.
In a blink, you might miss a news reader at the beginning of the movie
shining from another flickering light source.
Reporting riots of unemployed workers after tax reforms.
Maybe this is why Tetsuo and once the protagonist and the antagonist of the film
a boy who gains
extraordinary psychic power.
So often produces a disruption in the light around him.
Whether it's in his own mind
or in the form of an explosion
or in the Aura around him even in the vibrant dancing wavelength
that his brain patterns create.
Indeed, psychic power
most fully realize in Tetsuo and his counterpoint,
Akira.
Represent the only kind of power that can have an effect on the state of things in Neo Tokyo.
This is perhaps the reason that the protesters turned to Akira
for their salvation.
Because even when the authorities turned their biggest spotlight on him
a mega satellite laser that takes the name
of our son.
He comes out...
The Victor.
In the end the salvation represented in Tetsuo
comes at the cost of Ruin.
A catastrophe which consumes Neo Tokyo
in the form of a giant ball
of light.
One single uniform white light that erases the countless
artificial lights of the city.
Otomo seems to suggest that there's some freedom in this
some
rebirth as true sunlight wipes across the city in patches.
When you have to draw light
24 times in every second of a two-hour movie
it must be the case that you gain a new appreciation for how it can tell a story of its own.
And that's what Otomo and his crew have done in Akira.
Light is layered into the story
like...
it's layered into the animation cells.
Pointing toward meaning
behind the film at the corners of it.
And illuminating from different angles
the characters
and their place in this neon world.
In other words
Akira is a great example of how you animate
Light
Hey, everybody. It is great to be back home back to work and back on schedule.
Finally if you want to subscribe to this channel by the way, you can click right there that box over there
I have to thank Crunchyroll for sponsoring this video. If you don't know what my role is it's like a great service
where you can access tons of different anime shows and movies obviously I love anime
I love Akira, but you can get stuff like an hour after it airs on TV in Japan on Crunchyroll
I want to recommend one its Cowboy Bebop
If you haven't seen it it is an amazing and amazing show might actually analyze it sometime in the future,
but um anyway
They're a great service
They do really HD episodes you can get it on Apple TV
or Roku or whatever you have and if you sign up at
crunchyroll.com/nerdwriter
you can get a free 30-day trial
Which is awesome
And they're awesome for sponsoring the show without interfering in the content in any way or asking - thank you guys for that
And I'll see everybody else next Wednesday